[Música]
vamos directo a oval de texas allí está
nuestro enviado especial en mamen sala
con el cubrimiento de la masacre
ocurrida en la escuela el segundo peor
tiroteo en la historia del país y que
dejó 19 niños y dos profesoras
fallecidas también un buen día para
usted y ya empezaron a prepararse los
funerales de las víctimas que historias
puede reportarnos y cómo está la
comunidad ahora que yo va a ir en a
anunció su visita
muy buenos días angela desde aquí desde
oval de la comunidad sigue estando pues
como os podéis imaginar consternada
esperan esa visita del presidente yo
gaiden en los próximos días todavía no
sabemos exactamente cuando lo que sí han
empezado como decía son los preparativos
para los funerales muchas de las
funerarias que hay aquí en esta pequeña
población de no más de 16.000 habitantes
incluso han ofrecido de manera gratuita
sus servicios se están haciendo muchas
campañas de colecta de dinero para
ayudar a los familiares porque
recordemos que esta es una zona muy
humilde con un bajo poder adquisitivo y
en la que se están ayudando todo tendrá
que se están ayudando mucho unos a otros
se han guardado minutos de silencio en
prácticamente muchísimas ciudades de
todo el país en apoyo a esta horrorosa
matanza que hubo en este colegio como
decías hemos ido poco a poco conociendo
las historias de las víctimas
importante esas dos profesoras los
funcionarios dijeron que gracias a esas
dos profesoras incluso algunos niños
pudieron salvarse porque ellas mismas
con sus cuerpos protegieron a los
pequeños cuando comenzó
tiroteo y este tiroteo ha vuelto a poner
encima de la mesa angela un debate
eterno en este país que es el uso de las
armas vuelve a estar otra vez encima de
la mesa política y de hecho mañana mismo
tendrá lugar en houston en este mismo
estado donde ocurrió este horrible
tiroteo una convención de la asociación
nacional del rifle donde precisamente se
prevé que asista el ex presidente don al
tram y se espera que hable a favor de
las armas un dato curioso es que en esta
convención no se va a poder entrar con
armas ni con cuchillos para asistir
y además de eso pues se han conocido más
detalles sobre cómo sucedió este tiroteo
que se sabe
si angela se van conociendo más detalles
sobre el tiroteo y sobre todo sobre el
presunto autor de los hechos salvados
ramos de 18 años como ya todos sabemos
al parecer estaba obsesionado con las
armas amigos suyos cuentan que hace un
año colgó una fotografía en las redes
sociales diciendo que será su mejor
deseo tener unos rifles como los que
compró el 17 de mayo hace pocos días el
día de su cumpleaños de su 18 cumpleaños
en los que ya podía legalmente comprar
estas armas hemos sabido también que era
una persona muy solitaria con muchos
problemas porque al parecer vivía al
acoso constante de sus compañeros de
clase por un leve tartamudeo que tenía y
un cc.oo que tenía en el habla y esto al
parecer lo abría poco a poco aislado y
encerrado en sí mismo sus amigos cuentan
que era una persona muy tímida que sí
que de vez en cuando había hecho algunas
cosas raras contaba un amigo suyo en uno
de los medios nacionales como por
ejemplo hacerse varios cortes en la cara
simplemente por el disfrute de hacerlo
otros cuentan que habían escuchado
muchos gritos entre su madre y él
incluso la policía se había personado un
par de veces en la casa como podéis cómo
podéis ver una estructura familiar
complicada por eso vivía la mayor parte
del tiempo con su abuela allí se había
mudado hacía tres o cuatro meses una
abuela que intentó detenerlo cuando él
contó sus intenciones de que iba a
disparar en un colegio por eso le
disparó a ella una señora de 62 años que
recibió este disparo en la cara y se
encuentra en el hospital ahora en estado
crítico ayer escuchábamos también
declaraciones de su marido del abuelo
del presunto tirador que nos decía que
pues que no dan no dan crédito de lo que
ha ocurrido que no tenía ni idea de la
obsesión de su nieto con las armas